[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Freitagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen und die sportnachricht
des Tages die gibt es von Norbert König
ja Deutschland ist tatsächlich im Finale
und kann am Sonntag zum ersten Mal
Basketball Weltmeister werden heute
Abend und wir schauen auf ein Thema was
du ziemlich alle angeht egal ob sie zur
Miete oder im Eigenheim wohnen
Bundestag verabschiedet heizungsgesetz
ab 2024 sollen klimafreundlichere
Heizungen in Neubauten eingebaut werden
freie Wähler im Aufwind einen Monat vor
der bayerischen Landtagswahl kann die
Partei trotz flugblattaffäre zulegen die
CSU dagegen Büste im ZDF Politbarometer
Stimmen ein
[Applaus]
und Sensation in Manila die deutschen
Basketballer schlagen top Favorit USA
und könnten am Sonntag Weltmeister
werden
[Musik]
monatelang wurde um das sogenannte
heizungsgesetz politisch gerungen jetzt
ist es durch den Bundestag mit der
Mehrheit der Ampelkoalition der
Bundesrat befasst sich dann
wahrscheinlich Ende dieses Monats damit
schauen wir uns das Gesetz genauer an
es sieht vor dass ab nächstem Jahr neue
Heizungen mit mindestens 65 Prozent an
neuerbarer energiebetrieben werden
müssen erstmal nur in Neubauten für
Bestandsbauten gelten Ausnahmen und
mehrjährige Übergangsfristen selbst wenn
eine kommunale wärmeplanung vorliegt
beispielsweise zur Versorgung mit
Fernwärme der Staat fördert den
Austausch unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen mit bis zu 70% der
Kosten Karl Hinterleitner berichtet
umstritten verändert und immer wieder
verschoben heute war es soweit doch vor
der Verabschiedung gab es noch einmal
heftigen Streit gegen die überwältigende
Mehrheitsmeinung in der Bevölkerung und
in der Fachwelt Peitschen sie ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste hier heute ihr
gesetzt durch sie ignorieren die Ansage
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts sie
befördern Wut Frust Verdruss im Land ihr
heizungsgesetz ist ein
vertrauensverlustgesetz die Ampel
kontert die Opposition sei nur dagegen
und habe keine Alternative zu bieten
vielleicht kann man sich ja auch noch
mal dran erinnern wer Klimaschutzgesetz
und Klimaschutzziele hier gemeinsam
beschlossen hat und jetzt zu blockieren
und zu sagen wir nehmen das sogar noch
mal zurück das ist Misstrauen das ist
kein Vertrauen in Zukunft und das ist
das was sie hier heute gemacht haben
die Liberalen loben das Gesetz das lange
Ringen um Details habe sich gelohnt wir
wollen
die Heizung muss zum Haus passen und
nicht umgekehrt und so sollte sich der
Deutsche Bundestag entscheiden ich danke
Ihnen die Opposition von links und
rechts ist dagegen das Gesetz sei nicht
bezahlbar und unsozial
ihr Gesetz ist ein Handbuch zu
Vernichtung unseres Wohlstands sie
lassen die Mieterinnen und Mieter im
Stich sie bauen nicht nur keine Wohnung
sondern sie verteuern am Ende auch noch
die Mieten das ist doch die Wahrheit der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dagegen
zufrieden alle Interessen sein
angemessen berücksichtigt dieses
Gesetz sorgt dafür dass die Kommunen und
die Verbände mitgenommen werden es sorgt
für eine soziale Ausbalancierung des
Gesetzes es ist ein gutes Gesetz zum
Januar soll es in Kraft treten muss aber
zuvor noch in den Bundesrat der Streit
um das heizungsgesetz doch nicht vorbei
ganz durch ist das heizungsgesetz also
noch nicht Theo Colin Berlin was
bedeutet das konkret also konkret gilt
die Zustimmung im Bundesrat als eher
unproblematisch aber auch wenn vielen
Bürgern unter schließlich uns
journalistische Beobachter ja durchaus
mit ein nach dieser langen teils
chaotischen und vieles verheizenden
Entstehungsgeschichte sehr danach sein
sollte das Gesetz ist noch nicht ganz
durch es bleibt ein rechtliches Risiko
dennoch muss das Gesetz überhaupt
ordnungsgemäß zustande kommen unter
anderem gab es ja keine Beratungen in
den Ausschüssen mehr obwohl die
Oppositionen genau das ausdrücklich
gefordert hat sollte das
Bundesverfassungsgericht zum Schluss
kommen dass sie im Parlament nicht
genügend Zeit zur Beratung gegeben wurde
so jedenfalls lautet ja die Beschwerde
der Union dann könnte das Gesetz gekippt
werden gerechnet wird mit dem
Richterspruch im kommenden Jahr erst
dann kann man einen Strich darunter
machen oder es eben auch durchstreichen
also dieser Teil der Verbraucher verun
Sicherung der bleibt erstmal noch danke
für diese Einordnung
wie wird in Deutschland künftig geheizt
was ist zu beachten welche Zuschüsse
gibt es weitere Informationen und
Details zum heizungsgesetz finden Sie in
unserer ZDF heute App
sowohl in Hessen als auch in Bayern wird
in einem Monat ein neuer Landtag gewählt
wir schauen jetzt genau an die beiden
Bundesländer mit unserem aktuellen
ZDF-Politbarometer extra und dazu ist
Matthias von auf dem Studio guten Abend
Matthias blicken wir als erstes nach
Bayern was sagen denn die Befragten zum
Umgang mit der Flugblatt naja das
Skandal um das antisemitische Flugblatt
hat Wellen geschlagen aber ist das ein
Entlassungsgrund
das Ministerpräsident Söder Aiwanger im
Amt beläst finden 63% richtig 29% falsch
vor allem die Anhänger der Grünen aber
auch die der SPD finden die Entscheidung
mehrheitlich nicht richtig wenn am
Sonntag Landtagswahl wäre können wir die
CSU auf 36% grüne 16 Freie Wähler 16 AFD
spd9 und FDP
4%, die CSU hätte demnach eine Mehrheit
mit den freien WLAN aber auch mit den
Grünen und ganz knapp auch mit der SPD
ja und die neuen Zahlen des
politbarometers werden im Wahlkampf in
Bayern aufmerksam verfolgt die Reaktion
der Parteien hat Petra Neubauer
Hubert Aiwanger und die Affäre um
antisemitische Flugblätter haben in
diesen Wochen ordentlich Staub
aufgewirbelt dennoch ist der Chef der
Freien Wähler derzeit im Aufwind die
Menschen sehen dass wir gute
bürgerpolitik machen dass wir das Ohr
noch am Bürger haben dass wir noch
wissen was draußen los ist an den
Stammtischen nicht mit Ideologie von
oben die Leute zwangsbeglücken wollen
sondern sagen wir wissen was los ist
Ministerpräsident Söder nennt die
Umfragen nur eine Momentaufnahme und
übergeht damit dass seine CSU so
schlecht da steht wie lange nicht in
ernsten Zeiten man Söder dürfte man
keine Experimente machen im Endeffekt
auf die Frage an der Stabilität einer
Regierung und der stabile stark geteilt
das merkt man ja an allen Dingen das ist
natürlich die CSU und es ist vor allem
auch der Ministerpräsident die Grünen
haben als scharfe Kritiker in der
causaiwanger zwar profitiert jetzt aber
wollen sie zurück zum Wesentlichen wir
werden jetzt also weiter
leidenschaftlich für konsequenten
Klimaschutz für einer schnelleren Ausbau
von erneuerbaren Energien und für die
gleichen Startchancen für alle Kinder
kämpfen die AFD ist dem Aufwärtstrend
zeigt Sympathien für Aiwanger will sich
letztlich dennoch deutlich abgrenzen wer
die Freien Wähler wählt der wählt ein
weiter so der Regierung Söder und das
wollen die Menschen hier in Bayern nicht
und deswegen werden sie am Ende dann das
Kreuzchen bei der Alternative für
Deutschland machen im Umfragetief ist
weiterhin die bayerische SPD sie aber
sieht sich als das Bollwerk gegen
rechtsspopulismus hilft Bayern hilft den
Menschen überhaupt nicht weiter wie er
als SPD stehen für vernünftige Politik
wir wollen eine bezahlbares Bayern wir
wollen soziale Politik für die Menschen
machen für die FDP wird es wohl auch
diesmal wieder eine Zitterpartie umso
mehr setzt der Spitzenkandidat auf
Sachthemen eine starke Wirtschaft eine
gute Bildung für unsere Kinder ein
schlanker effizienter Staat ich glaube
das sind die Themen die auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wichtig sind
wichtiger als die Skandale und Affären
über die wir in den letzten Wochen
gesprochen haben
noch bleiben vier Wochen bis zur Wahl
noch sind aber auch 43
pro unsicher wie sie sich am Ende
entscheiden werden
und am 8 Oktober wird auch in Hessen
gewählt Matthias welcher Spitzenkandidat
oder Kandidatin kommt denn im
Politbarometer am besten an ja und wen
wünschen sich die Hessen als
Regierungschef den amtierenden
Ministerpräsidenten Boris rein 42
Prozent seinen Vize Tarek Al-Wazir 31
Prozent noch klarer der Vorsprung auf
die SPD-Kandidatin 50% wünschen sich
rein nur 26% nennt sie Fräser
wenn am Sonntag in Hessen gewählt wurde
käme die CDU auf 30% grüne 19 SPD 19 AFD
16 fdp6 und Linke
3%. demnach könnte die CDU weiter mit
den Grünen regieren oder aber auch mit
der SPD vielen Dank
und alle Zahlen des ZDF politbarometers
extra können Sie bei ZDF heute online
nachlesen
sie sollen geheime Informationen an den
russischen Geheimdienst FSB verraten
haben so lautet der Vorwurf gegen einen
Mitarbeiter des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes und einen
mutmaßlichen Komplizen die
Bundesanwaltschaft hat jetzt gegen die
beiden deutschen Anklage erhoben es geht
um besonders schweren Landesverrat jetzt
muss noch das Berliner Kammergericht
über die Zulassung der Anklage und einen
möglichen Prozess entscheiden
in die Ukraine das Land ist in der Nacht
wieder Ziel mehrerer russischer Angriffe
geworden vier Menschen wurden getötet
dutzende weitere verletzt auf einer
Konferenz sagte Präsident selenski die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive chemisch
schneller voran würde das Land
wirkungsvollere Waffen erhalten
in der Region saporicia war unsere
Reporter Henna Hebestreit mit der
ukrainischen Armee unterwegs in der Nähe
der Stadt ulriche unweiterfront
abgeschirmt durch einen Vorhang der vor
allem gegen die allgegenwärtigen
fliegenschützen soll statt Reka so sein
kampfname auf Monitore sie zeigen in
Echtzeit was auf russischer Seite der
Front vor sich geht seit Wochen Werte
der stundenlang solche drohnenbilder aus
wir haben den Krieg wirklich satt aber
wenn wir einfach die Hände in den Schoß
legen wird es ja nicht besser
ich kann nur sagen dass es mir so geht
dass ich meinen Rhythmus gefunden habe
man hört einfach auf die Erschöpfung zu
spüren man arbeitet weiter wie eine
Maschine
die Soldaten hier draußen erzählen wie
schwer es nach Beginn der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive war den Durchbruch durch
die russischen Linien zu schaffen
das Problem ist das schwere
Artilleriefeuer sobald du anfängst
voranzukommen fliegt sofort alles auf
dich zu man muss warten bis sich der
Beschuss etwas beruhigt hat aber der
Feind nutzt dann die Zeit sich neu
aufzustellen das macht alles so
schwierig
sie können überhaupt nicht sagen wann
die Gegenoffensive ihr Ziel erreicht
haben könnte zu viele Faktoren spielen
eine Rolle
ich kann ihnen nicht mal sagen welche
das sind aber einer ist zum Beispiel das
Wetter wenn es morgen anfängt zu regnen
kann es leicht passieren dass die
Offensive eine Woche auf Eis gelegt wird
sie werden sicher noch eine ganze Weile
hier sitzen und auf die drohnenbilder
starren um zu sehen was ihr russischer
Gegner an der Front gerade macht
und der Krieg in der Ukraine wird doch
eines der wichtigsten Themen beim
G20-Gipfel in Indien sein der Morgen
beginnt
19 große Industrie und Schwellenländer
und die EU sind in den G20 vertreten
aber wäre Zusammenarbeit deswegen vieler
Differenzen schwierig geworden die
Präsidenten Russlands und Chinas lassen
sich auf dem Gipfel vertreten und das
gebe Indien gibt sich sehr selbstbewusst
Premierminister Modi verfolgt vor allem
eigene Ziele Normen unter
Fortschritt gutes so hofften die
Menschen in Chanta Delhi werde der
G20-Gipfel Ihnen bringen dann kamen die
Bagger und machten ihren Slum platt 500
m von hier treffen sich die Mächtigen
der Welt so nah sollten Sie der Armut
nicht kommen
wir leben hier seit 25 30 Jahren und
jetzt reißen Sie einfach unsere Hütten
ab wo sollen wir denn hin ich verfluche
die Behörden sie haben keinen Platz für
uns uns bleibt nur die Straße
herausgeputzt schön gemacht verkleidet
auch wer Deli gut kennt hat die Stadt so
noch nicht gesehen sie ist eine Bühne
vor allem für den Gastgeber
nennen Sie mir einen Politiker auf der
Welt der Außenpolitik nicht auch für
eigene Zwecke und Ziele nutzt
Premierminister Modi ist genauso er will
dass alle seine Errungenschaften
bewundern Modis Indien strotzt vor Kraft
und Selbstbewusstsein doch alles hat
Kehrseiten das bevölkerungsreichste Land
der Erde zu sein bedeutet Massen müssen
ernährt werden brauchen Jobs Energie
Bildung die Kluft zwischen oben und
unten ist enorm und zwischen den
Religionen auch Modis Kurs ist Hindu
nationalistisch lässt wenig Raum für
Minderheiten indien ist ein umworbener
Partner aber kein leichter denn was
innenpolitisch gilt zeichnet sich auch
außenpolitisch ab auf die
Befindlichkeiten anderer nimmt die
Regierung wenig Rücksicht werden Modi
auf seiner Seite will der muss ihm was
bieten für ihn zählt Indien sonst wenig
es ist alles bereitet in Delhi die Bühne
für die Welt und ihre unterschiedlichen
Interessen der Gastgeber ist ein Makler
mit eigenen
der stark Ring in Griechenland ist
vorbei und allmählich wird das Ausmaß
der zerstörungssichtbar 11 Menschen
kamen ums Leben mehrere Orte sind noch
immer von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
seit Dienstag konnten laut Feuerwehr
fast 2000 Menschen gerettet werden
besonders betroffen von den
Überschwemmungen ist die Mitte
Griechenlands die Region Thessalien
Details haben Alexandra Vacano und
Annette hilsenbeck
sie retten wo und wie sie nur können und
die die sie hier in Larissa retten sind
am Ende ihrer Kräfte das Wasser will
nicht weichen hier erreicht der
Pegelstand gerade 9 m 50 normal sind
vier Meter alles ist überflutet es gibt
immer noch so viele Menschen die Hilfe
brauchen
in Palamas steht das Wasser immer noch
bis zu zwei Meter hoch stundenlang saßen
die Menschen hier fest jetzt ist die
griechische Armee da mit sich
rettungsboten
wir leiden und werden noch sehr lange
leiden die Schäden an unseren Häusern
lassen sich nicht mehr reparieren die
Arbeit eines ganzen Lebens ist innerhalb
kürzester Zeit völlig zerstört
am Mittag sieht Ministerpräsident mit
sotages was die Wassermassen in seinem
Land angerichtet haben die Orte carediza
und tricola komplett überschwemmt man
werde alles Menschenmögliche tun sagt er
dies ist nicht nur die größte
Flutkatastrophe die Griechenland hier
erlebt hat es ist auch eine der größten
die es je in Europa gab und ich erwarte
europäische Hilfe und das Europa es
schafft mehr Mittel zu mobilisieren
welche Kraft das Wasser hatte zeigt sich
hier wo mal eine Brücke stand jetzt
bringt die Feuerwehr Menschen per
Seilzug in Sicherheit die Region sie
gilt als Kornkammer Griechenlands die
Felder sind mittlerweile zerstört und
die Ernte wohl auch
heute warnt der Katastrophenschutz vor
Überschwemmungen weil die Flusspegel
steigen der Regen hat zwar aufgehört
aber jetzt sammelt sich das Wasser in
den größeren Flüssen und die treten über
die Ufer und sorgen für neue
Überschwemmungen die Gefahr ist noch
nicht gebannt und hier in wolhus Kämpfen
sie jetzt gegen den Schlamm immerhin der
Strom funktioniert wieder doch langsam
gehen Trinkwasser und Lebensmittel aus
ein mutmaßlicher Brandanschlag hat den
Zugverkehr zwischen Hamburg und Berlin
beeinträchtigt dutzende Züge auf der
wichtigen Verbindung und auch im
Regionalverkehr vielen aus laut Polizei
setzten die Täter vergangenen Nacht an
drei Stellen in Hamburg Kabelschächte in
Brand die ermittelnden gehen von einem
politischen Hintergrund aus eine linke
Gruppe hat sich zu der Tat bekannt
Verkehrsminister Wissing bezeichnete den
Vorfall als eine Form von Terrorismus
künstliche Intelligenz ist derzeit in
aller Munde eine die seit Jahren in
diesem Bereich forscht ist die deutsche
Informatikerin Cordelia Schmid sie ist
jetzt mit dem körperpreis für
europäische Wissenschaft ausgezeichnet
worden im Hamburg bekam sie die mit
einer Million Euro dotierte Auszeichnung
mit arbeitet daran dass Computer
Gegenstände nicht nur sehen können
sondern diese auch erkennen und dann
sinnvoll reagieren
Zusammenhalt gemeinsam auch als
Kontrapunkt zu Demokratie feindlichen
Entwicklungen in Deutschland das ist das
was der Bundespräsident beim Bürgerfest
im Schloss Bellevue in den Mittelpunkt
stellt und so sind heute 3000
ehrenamtliche geladen sie alle seien
Vorbilder Mutmacher und das Rückgrat der
deutschen Demokratie so Steinmeier jetzt
Schneider hat einen von ihnen getroffen
Stefan Quarz ist mit seiner Frau aus
Treben in Thüringen angereist als er die
Einladung ins Schloss Bellevue bekommen
hat hielt er es erst für Werbung aber
hinten war dann der eingeprägte
Emblem drauf und da haben wir es
aufgemacht und war ich war erschrocken
seit Jahren kümmert er sich ehrenamtlich
um Flüchtlinge hilft bei Wohnungs
Jobsuche und der Bürokratie auch Josef
kusak aus Syrien unterstützt er ich
stolpere immer etwas über das Wort
Ehrenamt ich empfinde das nicht als
Ehrenamt sondern als Menschlichkeit da
ich nicht allen helfen kann habe ich mir
gedacht
ich helfe einzelnen und dann weiß ich
was ich gemacht habe und Krieg auch die
direkte Antwort
mittlerweile als Schweißer Stefan Quad
den Hausarzt im Ruhestand freut das sehr
der Bundespräsident hat ehrenamtliche
Helferinnen und Helfer aus ganz
Deutschland zum Sommerfest eingeladen er
nennt sie Vorbilder für alle
[Applaus]
drücken dass wir in dieser Zeit noch
stärker zeigen und noch lauter sagen
unser Land bleibt ein Land der
Mitmenschlichkeit und des Gemeinsinns
letztes Jahr musste das Fest wegen
Unwetterwarnung abgebrochen werden das
ist heute nicht zu befürchten
zum ersten Mal gelingt den deutschen
Basketballern bei einem wichtigen
Turnier ein Sieg gegen die USA und das
bedeutet Finale
können wir uns am Sonntag ab 14 Uhr hier
im ZDF anschauen
100:13 gegen 111 gegen das Mutterland
des Basketballs Deutschlands beste
Profis schweben in Manila auf Wolke 7
nun soll gegen Serbien im WM Finale auch
die absolute Krönung gelingen
nach einem unglaublichen Krimi brechen
alle Dämme Außenseiter Deutschland hat
es tatsächlich geschafft der große
Favorit USA geschlagen es ist ein
verdienter Sieg der noch einmal in
Gefahr gerät als die US-Amerikaner durch
Anthony Edwards auf drei Punkte
herankommen Deutschland hatte bereits 12
Punkte Vorsprung gehabt der überragende
Andreas Obst aber behält in der großen
Hektik die Ruhe drei Punkte zum 111 zu
107 und Kapitän Dennis Schröder
übernimmt Verantwortung sein Körper
folgt notwendig denn am Ende bleiben
zwei Punkte Vorsprung
euch könnte jeden jeden junge rausnehmen
weil
einfach einfach von vorne bis hinten
einfach nur geil die Puppe ja und
einfach weiter gespielt und ich glaube
am Ende auch verdient gewonnen zum
ersten Mal zieht Deutschland in ein WM
Finale ein Gegner am Sonntag das Team
aus Serbien
und Deutschland gegen Japan heißt es in
Wolfsburg beim Start der
Fußballnationalmannschaft in die
EM-Saison wird morgen Ilkay Gündogan als
verlängerte Arm von Bundestrainer Flick
die Mannschaft aufs Feld führen
gegen WM Schreck Japan ein neues
Spielsystem und ein neuer Kapitän
Ilkay Gündogan wird überraschend
befördert soll noch mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen nach der zuletzt scharfen
Kritik steht Hansi Flick vor seiner
bislang schwierigsten Etappe als
Bundestrainer wir wissen alle dass das
Spiel morgen oder auch gegen Frankreich
für uns sehr wichtig ist und und
deswegen wollen wir uns da gut
vorbereiten und wollen natürlich alles
nur die Spiele reinlegen Flick hat heute
bestätigt dass Rückkehrer Niklas süle in
der Startelf steht
im sogenannten Kuss Skandal um den
inzwischen suspendierten spanischen
fußballverbandspräsidenten Luis hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft die Einleitung eines
Ermittlungsverfahrens wegen sexueller
Belästigung und Nötigung beantragt ein
Untersuchungsrichter wird jetzt über die
Zulassung des Strafantrags entscheiden
ressourreiterin Jessica von Bredo Werndl
hat ihren Europameistertitel im Grand
Prix Spezial erfolgreich verteidigt die
Olympiasiegerin feierte im Sattel von
der Lehrer einen überlegen Sieg und gilt
am Sonntag in Riesenbeck zum Abschluss
auch als klare Favoritin in der Tür
und morgen Abend erwartet uns ein
royales Sportstudio zu Gast ist Prinz
Harry der Duke of Sussex danke Norbert
auch die nächsten Tage werden
spätsommerlich wann sich daran etwas
ändert das erfahren Sie gleich von Katja
horneffer
um 22 Uhr gibt es das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend der Spätsommer hält noch ein
Weilchen durch denn das Hoch Patricia
wird sich erst ganz allmählich Anfang
der kommenden Woche nach Osten
verabschiedet und so werden die Tiefs
auf Distanz gehalten dieses Tief dass
die Unwetter über Griechenland gebracht
hat erreicht inzwischen die Küste
Nordafrikas heute Nacht ist es bei uns
klar selten bildet sich etwas Nebel und
die Temperaturen sinken auf Werte
zwischen 17 Grad am Niederrhein und 10
Grad in Bayern und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 26 Grad im
Allgäu und 33 Grad am Oberrhein und es
gibt morgen wieder sehr viel
Sonnenschein vielleicht ziehen über den
Nordwesten ein paar hohe Wolkenfelder
hinweg und aus den Alpen heraus sind da
nachmittags einige Quellwolken nicht
völlig ausgeschlossen aber viele von
ihnen werden morgen wieder so 11 bis 13
Sonnenstunden erleben können das
allerdings wird sich bis zur Wochenmitte
ändern dann wird es nämlich deutlich
schattiger dann erwarten uns nur noch so
ein bis fünf Sonnenstunden für einen
ganzen Tag und spätestens in der Nacht
auf Dienstag beginnt es dann kräftig zu
schütten und es geht heftige Gewitter
bis dahin aber ist es noch sehr sonnig
und warm in Deutschland guten Abend